bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de skins hague
apprentissage alternance lycée masseur
bts ou encore formation continue quelle
que soit la filière choisie la formation
est au coeur de la réussite
professionnelle et de l'emploi
universités grandes écoles école du
numérique ont fait le point sur la
formation à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est parti
[Musique]
je sors mi h chants licence mit h mais
mathématiques informatique appliquée le
soir humaines et sociales
je suis en double licence de droit
anglais d'éco-gestion j'ai choisi cette
filière pascal année plusieurs mètres
matière qui m'intéressait est-ce que je
suis intéressé par les métiers de
l'enseignement et l'économie
m'intéressait c'est assez complet cette
diversité
plutôt bien réputée dans les meilleures
universités on va dire dans le
classement
elle est plus proche de chez moi et elle
était bien aller bien reconnu c'était la
faute de proximité c'est plutôt aussi
bien localisé je trouve on est dans une
bonne ville il ya plein de magasins à
proximité
enfin c'est vraiment très très bien
[Musique]
alors ici c'est une séquelle de promat
isme crânien dont un patient de
rééducation de l'hôpital raymond
poincaré reconnu au niveau international
l'université de versailles saint quentin
compte parmi les vingt universités en
tête du classement de shanghaï lu vs qu
est aussi la deuxième université au
monde en terme d'enseignements sur les
sciences de l'atmosphère
[Musique]
implanté sur divers sites de saint
quentin en yvelines et de versailles
elle offre 22 filière de licence dont
cinq filières avec des doubles diplômes
15 des ut diverses licences
professionnelles et 45 mentions de
master autant de possibilités de
formation pour les étudiants du
territoire est d'ailleurs l'université
versailles accueille au sein de ses
inscrits à peu près 13 % d'étudiants
étrangers on développe ses partenariats
et la mobilité internationale avec les
universités européennes mais également à
l'international où cela permet de
rayonner au niveau international les
étudiants viennent en échange chez-nous
six mois ou un peu plus
et évidemment nos étudiants vont
également à l'étranger et donc ça
favorise bien évidemment les échanges et
les transferts de connaissances autres
partenaires l'université paris saclay lu
vs qu en est une composante à part
entière
lancé en 2008 l'université paris saclay
regroupe trois universités neuf grandes
écoles et cet organisme de recherche à
peu près deux tiers des masters
aujourd'hui sont des masters accrédité
par l'université paris 5 t nous les
développons en partenariat avec
agroparistech avec centrale supélec avec
paris sud ou encore l'université d'evry
donc ce sont des formations qu'on
mutualisent sa femme aux étudiants
bénéficier de connaissances qui sont
créés à partir de synergies entre les
différentes équipes de recherche c'est
évidemment une université qui m
kim universités qui vise au rayonnement
international d'une percée de recherche
la rayonnement international et on y
contribuer pleinement au regard de nos
forces en recherche d'informations et
pour mettre en pratique les
connaissances acquises sur les bancs de
la fac
les étudiants peuvent profiter des
grandes entreprises basées sur le
territoire saint quentinois
l'université est implanté sur un
territoire qui qu'elle veut notamment
sur le pôle de saint quentin le deuxième
pôle économique de l'ouest prend ce
francilien donc évidemment on a un très
grand nombre de partenaires et le tissu
économique local c'est qu'en fait ça ça
crée des terrains de stage et une bonne
insertion professionnelle qui est très
bonne pour les étudiants me dodji excuse
mais également ça nous permet nous de
répondre aux besoins de ces entreprises
en termes de formation tout au long de
la vie c'est à dire que ces entreprises
ont des besoins en se dotant ça peut
être la cybersécurité ça peut être des
techniques de pointe en termes de ve de
développement durable ou encore de santé
et universités est en mesure de répondre
à ces besoins automobile aéronautique
finances de nombreuses entreprises ont
choisi l'agglomération pour y implanter
leur siège social
une proximité qui a son importance c'est
fondamental puisque c'est là encore une
synergie c'est à dire que c'est la
création de connaissances ce sont des
échanges et on bénéficie de jésus voilà
du terrain des entreprises et les
entreprises nous apporte énormément
parce qu'elles sont sur le terrain ça
nous permettrait alors is est ce qu'on
sait faire
prochaine collaboration pour
l'université celle avec le cesa bhl
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité tout nouvellement
installée à guyancourt
une naissance professionnel vient d'être
créée du ceap et aux études d'ingénieur
le sésame permet de répondre à
l'engouement des jeunes pour le secteur
mais également de pallier aux besoins
des entreprises
[Musique]
nous arrivons en plein cours de
mécanique la théorie avant la pratique
dans l'atelier attenant
implanté depuis un an et guyancourt le
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité est un centre de
formation d'excellence
ici on travaille l'automobile la moto et
le vélo l'originalité du campus c'est
qu'on retrouve plusieurs entités
plusieurs opérateurs de formation sur un
même site
et c'est ce qui fait justement la force
de cette de cet endroit si le campus
existe aujourd'hui notamment sur
guyancourt c'est suite justement un
besoin entreprises qui s'est fait
ressentir ces dernières années
auxquelles justement n'avaient pas
d'offre de formation donc le campus a
vraiment un intérêt c'est l'objet
l'objectif premier c'est de répondre aux
besoins en main d'oeuvre des entreprises
de la branche des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
cette fois nous voici en atelier moto
pour quelques petits ajustements je vais
faire un cqp été lavé m chez bmw futile
après le bac c'est une formation
professionnelle qui permet d'approfondir
ses compétences dans une marque
j'aimais beaucoup la marque bmw je
voulais me professionnaliser dans la
marque et c'était la formation adéquate
nous sommes la première section c'est la
seule école bmw je me sens enfin on est
une petite équipe et c'est vraiment je
me sens vraiment bien
c'est vraiment une bonne formation c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours passionné
depuis j'étais petit
cette sensation de liberté ii
de performance c'est comme un univers je
pense offert quelques années chez bmw et
après me spécialiser en compétition le
sésame accueillent tous publics jeunes
demandeurs d'emploi salariés et personne
en phase de reconversion avec un projet
de création ou reprise d'entreprise
apprentissage contrat de
professionnalisation ces apps et bac pro
bts jusqu'au diplôme d'ingénieur le
campus propose aussi des diplômes de
branche comme le cqp techniciens experts
après vente et cqp dépannage remorquage
le seul diplôme de ce type
dispensée en ile de france et puis à la
rentrée 2010 9 on proposera une licence
professionnelle organisation management
des services de l'automobile
ça se fait en lien avec l'université de
saint quentin en yvelines on travaille
depuis sept à huit mois et du 16 au 23
mars
le campus ouvrira ses portes à celles et
ceux intéressés par ces métiers qui
recrutent
[Musique]
universités et grandes écoles permet
ainsi de répondre aux besoins de ces
secteurs en tension sur le territoire la
collaboration avec les entreprises est
permanente
qu'il est bon de noter adhérents
préalable c'est effectivement le large
panel de formations qui est offert à
tous nos étudiants de saint quentin en
yvelines puis que nous allons de cinq
campus universitaire jusqu'à intégrer
également de très nombreuses grandes
écoles dont certaines sont renommés
comme l'estaca dans le milieu de
l'aéronautique et du transport comme
l'institut de l'image et du son
troisième ce qui est le premier pôle
privé européen de l'image et du son est
tout d'abord l'estac à l'école forme des
ingénieurs dans les quatre secteurs des
transports aéronautique automobile
spatial et transports urbains et
ferroviaires
l'estac assez près de deux mille deux
cents étudiants 340 diplôme par an 91 %
des étudiants en activité avant la fin
de leur cursus dont 55 % occupent une
fonction ayant des liens à
l'international 70 % des enseignants
sont des ingénieurs en activité
troisième l'institut supérieur de
l'image et du son basé à elancourt est
un centre de formation aux métiers de
l'image du son et du spectacle 1500
étudiants ils sont formés 300
productions sont réalisées chaque année
par les étudiants troisième et le plus
grand campus d'europe dédié aux arts
créatifs les parcours de bac à bac + 5
sont répartis en sept filières dont la
toute dernière design graphique motion
design depuis 2018 l'établissement a
obtenu un diplôme visé pour la filière
cinéma audiovisuel et sont une belle
reconnaissance pour les 30 ans de
l'école
autre formation pour un secteur qui a le
vent en poupe le numérique le territoire
a lancé son label campus de numérique
ceci pour répondre aux exigences des
entreprises en 2018 cet organisme et 13
formations de bac à bac + 2 ont été
labellisés
[Musique]
devenir développeur programmeurs
community managers ont expert en
cybersécurité
le secteur recrute depuis 2018 des
organismes comme simplon pops cool il
faut coop o'clock web force 3 ou encore
le cnam propose la formation
ceci n'est qu'une première étape puisque
nous allons poursuivre cette évolution
en 2019
avec également des ciblages sur ce
numérique et sur la cybersécurité nous
avons un panel économique au niveau au
niveau du territoire avec toutes les
grandes entreprises ce qui fait que
c'est un atout pour pouvoir attirer ses
écoles et ses formations supplémentaires
puisque il est il est pour un étudiant
très important de disposer sur le
territoire de formation d'un potentiel
pour obtenir dans un premier temps des
stages dans un second temps l'emploi des
pme jusqu'aux grands groupes la demande
en personnel qualifié est importante en
2018 dix mille offres d'emploi ont été
proposées sur le territoire une partie
n'a pas trouvé preneur
[Musique]
autre formation d'excellence
le lycée d'hôtellerie et de tourisme de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'établissement propose des formations
de la seconde à la licence dans des
secteurs qui recrutent cuisine
boulangerie pâtisserie management en
hôtellerie restauration en 2016 le lycée
a enregistré plus de 90 % de réussite
aux examens est ce qui prouve bien que
la formation c'est tout un panel s'est
pas uniquement des grandes écoles ou des
universités
mais c'est tout un panel de formations
mises à disposition des étudiants
la formation de nos étudiants c'est la
richesse de notre économie pour plus
tard donc il importe avant tout que
cette formation soit adaptée à nos
besoins
et comme nos besoins vont sans cesse
évoluer il est important que cette
formation ne soit pas statique
vous savez tous désormais sur les
filières les formations et les écoles
rendez-vous le mois prochain pour un
numéro spécial emploi
ciao
[Musique]